أعتقد أنه من شبه المؤكد أنه ما
زال على قيد الحياة ، هذا رأيي الشخصي ،
لكن أه أعتقد
أنهم قلقون جدًا بشأن ما
حدث لأسامة بن لادن حتى أنه حتى
أدنى علامة على الحياة
أه قد تؤدي إلى اكتشافه  الآن
هناك تكلفة لذلك أيضًا إذا لم تتمكن من
إنتاج ما يسمى بالزعيم ، فسوف
يستنتج الناس أنه مات
وأن هناك العديد من
الحلفاء كما هو مسموح به كمثال جيد
الأشخاص الذين خرجوا للتو من شاشة الرادار ،
فما يقول ذلك أعتقد هو  أن
جهود الإرهابيين
في الإخفاء أه
ما زالت أه
ناجحة ولهذا السبب لا يزالون يشكلون تهديدًا ،
فهذا أحد الأسباب التي كنت
أعارض بشدة انسحاب القوات الأمريكية
من أفغانستان لأنني أعتقد أنه
على الرغم من جهودنا الأفضل سنخسر
المعلومات الاستخباراتية الحيوية من عدم الوجود.
على الأرض هناك